what's he want to happen he just like
busted into his mom's roommate Martin
Luther King
so Jordan truth parrot be in the Tubman
like when you want from these moves
[Music]
there's a father white guy
39 he wants to know if he's the [__]
in this situation yes all right this
one's a little I don't know I like
saying yesterday he's got a 17 year old
son who has a lovely and delightful new
girlfriend that everybody Danny Boulder
no sorry I killed him
his new girlfriend she comes over a lot
they have a great time no problems with
her at all however she is black
which is not a problem except that
father has his mother visiting because
she's staying there because she's had
surgery so he's got to have her come
over so this is this kid's grandmother
she's a classic old-timey racist okay so
classic racist
she doesn't want to see this black
girlfriend in the house when she's there
got it so let's already put out that
request hey I'm gonna come over I don't
want to see this yeah she put the
request out that she does not want that
girl coming to the house while she's
there the father he doesn't have the
option of putting her in a home or
nothing that's his mom he there's just
nothing else he doesn't have the money
to house or somewhere else he's like
she's gotta stay so he's sorry my mom's
a racist yeah he makes a deal with his
son he says I hate that we have to do
this but your girlfriend just cannot
come over she's kind of Uninvited from
all the holiday things that are coming
up while mom is here just wait for gam
gam to die yeah exactly that's his
attitude about it wow but his son of
course like he's in love he's not gonna
understand that the same way my dick's
so hard dad his son is calling him a
complacent racist
oh that's some whack [__] right there a
complacent race how old is the sun 17.
that's why here's here's the thing with
that right this is what I dislike about
me as a young person too and just
younger people in general right there
are things that you want to try to do
that will never [__] happen yeah that
old person will never change their
perspective you will waste your [__]
breath to the day they die wait till
they die wait till they [__] die you
are the Next Generation that's going to
set a positive example you're not going
to change her it's not going to [__]
happen right and she's not gatekeeping
anything she has no power exact sense if
she actually held a position where she
can affect the lives of people and she's
saying don't bring your black friends
around and I'm never gonna give them a
job or some [__] like that you know
where she can hold them from anything
it's just she has a stupid opinion and
imagine this too right so like the dad
comes and he goes I got you he starts
screaming at his mom who's on the verge
of [__] death right what happens here
nothing [__] changes the only thing
that really happens is that your whole
life the whole family Dynamic is going
to be [__] up yeah your father's gonna
be the person that got to yell at his
[__] dying [__] mom mom's gonna
hate them the the daughter's not gonna
have a great time being there watching
the dad [__] yell at the grandma the
son's in a weird awkward position bring
his [__] girlfriend over to get
[__] hated on vocally girlfriend
might break up with him just because
she's like yo you're a [__] Grandma's
racist think with the with with the
lofty idea of what is right right but
necessarily what is right doesn't mean
that it's best for the situation right
and the situation dictates that if she
did come over and your dad took a stance
how awkward is that for her how terrible
would that Grandma make her feel how bad
do you think that situation is going to
be here's the hard thing everybody who's
like a new [__] adult like 17 18 in
their 20s remember that feeling your 20s
you're like I'm Gonna Change the World
right and then you're [__] in your
30s and you're like I'm hoping that my
world is good yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's all when you're in your 30s
you pick and choose your battle yeah
right you gotta assess every single
situation and then you go is it really
worth the fight and does the fight
produce an actual result that does
anything good in this situation I don't
think it does anything I also think the
father is actually like
super nice yeah because he agrees with
the kids consider the kids feelings
because ultimately he pays the bills his
rules right his house his rules yeah if
you want your girl to come over
go get your own place get a job and she
can come over whenever she wants I think
the dad actually has a duty to his mom
so it's his house his rules and look
look at this too like look how great
your father was that even though his mom
is a blatant racist he isn't right
that's pretty [__] good he got better
from the generation before yeah he could
have been taught that racism and held on
to it but he was like nah like I'm gonna
accept that my son can have you know
what I mean this black girlfriend but
it's just I understand there's a point
of friction here that does no good for
anybody so I'm gonna like ask that you
like not do this like like the idea that
he went out he's like oh you're a
complacent racist like what does that do
for your relationship with your father
right makes it real good what does that
do right like your dad is trying to
think about the best scenario for the
best situation right to avoid conflict
as a whole well he probably just wants
his like he's thinking immediate because
he's at my airport
I want my dad to have my back and fight
my grandma and we should get rid of all
racism in this household like that's the
ideology of a 17 year old who wants
things fixed immediately yeah and I'm
like if this [__] has been thinking
like this for 80 years what makes you
think one conversation is gonna change
at all right it's just not going to
happen right and and I think like a lot
of people will hear this especially if
you're really young and you go well does
that make it right no it doesn't [__]
make it we're not talking we all
disagree that yeah we all think that
racism is [__] horrible and that
[__] but we also are realistic of
this old [__] being so [__] set in
their ways that's probably why the path
of least resistance here and to keep the
most peace is the is what the dad did
because it's going to cause problems for
everybody yeah and the end result is
great the changes already happened
racist Mom has a son who isn't racist so
the positive change is already there so
right
so if your father was blatantly racist
and he is just a chip off the old block
then there's like a an issue for you to
stand up right
but the changes already happened like
it's already good minus this old person
who's literally like five six years away
from passing away her opinion and the
movements that she's going to make is
not going to have a ripple effect on
anybody it's done it died with her son
yep yeah so it's great you know what I
mean but I understand because when
you're young too like your parents don't
like your girlfriend you're gonna lash
out you don't [__] know her at all
you don't know what I'm going that's
what makes it hard to say like what do
you think would be enough for a person
that's on the absolute opposite side of
that like like this kid like what would
be enough yeah they should just like
dies now is that how to suck his mom in
the mouth so if I was the girlfriend I'd
feel one rejected by the family but if I
knew that the father was chill with me
yeah and I'd like to have a conversation
with him yeah like I I wish I hope the
father was talking to him hey like I
like you you're a cool ass person I'm in
a tough situation yeah this is my way of
reasoning of the best result I think
this is the way to do it right um and
you're welcome to come in for other
occasions and when grandma's not around
but I have a duty and obligation to the
person who raised me yeah like yeah she
might be a racist but was she a bad
mother was she abusive was she because
obviously if he's doing his duty as a
son I'm thinking she did a decent job to
that he's giving her a space you know so
like
it's really hard to have these absolutes
where you're like I won't [__] have
any racists in this house but then
because what if
she's in the house and that's
opportunity for dialogue between the son
and Grandma and be like you know once in
a while they could have conversations
about racism and she might come and turn
around who knows but it takes more than
one conversation it takes a long time
dude it takes a long [__] time to
change somebody it doesn't want to
happen he just like busted into his
mom's [__] room hey [__] Martin
Luther King
so Jordan truth parrot be in the Tubman
like what do you want from these moves
these are legit moves damn you did three
of them George Washington Carver and
it's like it's already too late because
it it's like the girlfriend knows
already yeah so it's like it's our yeah
she already knows this is happening
because she's not allowed at the house
so it's already too late like you're not
gonna save her from knowing at all but
at least you're saving her from what she
might never be able to unhear from some
old coot that's like having a crazy
moment you know there are gonna be so
many times when you guys grow up and you
realize how much time you [__] wasted
over petty [__] man like I [__] you know
what I mean like I know
younger brother who didn't talk to his
mom for eight years because so the mom
didn't like the girl eight years you
wasted not talking to your mother
because she didn't like your girl and by
the way they [__] broke up so it's
like she [__] dumped him so like you
wasted all that time hating on this one
person because she had an opinion about
the girl that you were with that you
weren't engaged to that you didn't even
[__] marry like they probably stayed
together longer to prove a point maybe
dude but that's like it's it's such a
[__] waste time is so you never get
10 back and I know it'd be impossible
for that dude at age 17 to see further
than [__] one week but like unless
you're Nick done how many people stay
with their 17 year old sweetheart you
know what I'm saying like you grow you
change people learn new things they
discover new things they enter new
environments like college and they
[__] me way more fine chicks and I'm
just kidding but the point is you know
what I'm saying like when you're so
young too that father's also got an
obligation that father has an obligation
to his own wisdom and experiences yeah
to also be like all right look like
you're not even a [__] adult yet like
I've got to make multi-generational
decisions that are so complex you know
if one party doesn't understand and then
his older his mom also don't understand
something he's like all right I'm the
only one that's got enough capacity to
make a decision no matter if it vilifies
me for this moment being stuck in the
middle is hard yeah he's got a hard
situation Yeah by default like you kind
of have to be right if I was in the dad
situation I actually would tell my mom
shut the [__] up and you're living in my
house now this is my son this is his
girlfriend you're gonna sit here and
you're just gonna get to learn how to so
he is [__] I don't think he's [__]
and this is the reason why I feel this
way that I can do it this way because
my my relationship with my mom hasn't
always been the greatest so I can speak
to her in a certain way because she
didn't perform her complete duties as a
mother sometimes shut up [__] so she has
to deal with it
the situation I don't know I don't know
how he grew up with his mom I have no
idea right but for me I have no guilt
controlling my own household and telling
her no you're in my house now you do
what I say but that wouldn't necessarily
cure her racism it wouldn't cure it but
at the same time shut her ass up but
that also might cause her to act out you
know I mean even more so like but to me
that's more of a power of like burn
across in the law to prove a point but
that to me is like you can have your
beliefs but you're not gonna come in and
and have power over my household and say
like don't bring this person in no [__]
that that's my kid and that's his
girlfriend and we're gonna have holidays
with them yeah you know and then if you
have a thing or two about it keep it to
yourself that's all I would say and also
too like for him as a young person right
did you talk to your girlfriend and ask
her if she wants to bear that burden
yeah before coming in and trying to
change this old person's mind exactly
she has to walk in and and show her this
this this multitude of kindness to chair
change her mind about how she feels
about an ethnicity that she hated her
whole life did you ask her if she's
willing to bear that cross yeah that's a
lot of responsibility on the girlfriend
dude yeah and it's it's fair that the
Dad should have a say in whether or not
that fight even happens he could just be
like nah I don't care what you guys
think let her die with these expired
views yeah because I'm already working
my ass off to [__] provide for
everyone right now like you know there's
enough work like you know what I mean
going around that is why I'm conflicted
because it's like if you know something
might go down and it's going to be
awkward during Thanksgiving do you
really want that to go down yeah imagine
if she was Native American
hey how are you hey how are you
[Music]
thank you